[Musica]
se musica per faty lamentevole mente
questa musica soprattutto ben altri
ragazzi ben vedere solo video sarà un
paio dei senati suo aprile questa
domenica come tutte le domeniche
mamma mia sono ritornati alle vecchie
glorie e strano dire queste cose ma è
vero e mi piace questa faccenda
mentre lo scorso episodio fatto i
livelli della settimana questo episodio
capaccio livelli del mese però a vedere
un po come sono messi partiamo con easy
facciamo ultra high sfogo fi no fermi vi
ricordo che proprio fight queste la
volevano di superare i tipi ma ediziona
la vita sono inventato apposta posto
posto sono più che stai bene quanto pare
sì vado
[Applauso]
mamma mia che salvataggio incredibile
katana betti si chiamava sta tizia verga
tutto bene quel che finisce con una
spada nel petto life tranquillo ecco
adesso non è tanto bene purtroppo per
chi non conoscesse se non si tocca la
faccia tutto a posto possono infilza
arti dagli atti gli arti se la faccia e
sta a posto stai a posto pur i due se la
facciano sta a posto muori poi ragazzi
suo livello è difficile più di quanto
pensiate ve lo dico io ma l'edizione era
un po che non facevano poco fight
ragazzi se devo essere sincero let's go
world john la frutta a chi è piaciuta di
la verità allora piano ti prego va bene
va bene e manca lui di penultimo ragazzi
è difficilissimo
puoi toglierti che mi dai fastidio non
riesco a saltare grazie perfetto a
maledizione va beh siamo arrivati molto
avanti va bene lo stesso o rock swing mi
rilassano in partenza allora io mi devo
lanciare questa corda qui si frizza
let's go oggi non sono in perfetta forma
se dobbiamo dire però fa niente allora
figlia mo stormo qua per favore grazie
molto bene tutto sto casino se vogliamo
metterlo in mezzo è dovuto al fatto che
è di
non sa prendere la strada il marciapiede
normalmente si deve fare questi giri
sulle ro ro p
sulle corde come sincero va in inglese e
in italiano corda era finto porca vacca
che serve non l'avevo mai vista
non sapevo si potesse piegare l'arrivo
fichissimo danger pregio ma io quei
pericoli ci vado a nozze
bene è qualcosa mi dice che finiremo a
pezzi però fa niente
violo tutto a posto finché mio figlio
può muoversi va bene vai figlio
vai figlio io credo in te vai figlio ma
il figlio
onde evitare di storni mie orecchie dai
fai questo giro decennio perché riesco a
fare sto giro come by yoox tra l'interno
l'ex co mio dio
e fa niente facciamo che non andiamo di
backflip di front lip che dici che dite
facciamo sta roba da spezia dritto però
stai dritto dritto
mio dio cliente io devo accompagnare
tutto il livello e mentre questo fi.gi
alla morte c'è mio dio è un casino a
posto mamma mia ragazzi sopravvive in
corso come però va bene vedo il
traguardo
eccolo
mamma mia ragazzi che giocata
incredibile non so come ho fatto a
vincere prova importante aver vinto
michael sfard ha pattato man datato man
06 allora il becco lo avevo capito dal
titolo zio lo spy fonti di buttare e
morire e capire perché nella tua vita
non hai mai avuto successi questo
proveniva
ma non sempre va così a quanto pare bene
lo trovo 1.1 facciamolo purtroppo meglio
io vi giuro la spada il machete non l'ho
mai capito la katana la katana a tutto
un suo perché arabi a1 a2 a3 questa l'ha
fatto con due colpi ne ho fatti fuori
due ottimi dopodiché cesto bambino
quartet e all'appoggio proprio della
pace
sto mancato volevo fare il figo mano
mancato lo sa bene e poi c'è come ultimo
il bullo che ti ha chiama che ti ha dato
del ciccione a me amico mio nessun parma
dove lo cicero perché peso come una
pagina diario bagnata
quindi mi sa che non fa niente cioè
farebbe ridere sentite squadra riuscisse
a non prenderlo mai cosa molto probabile
ma invece no effetto all importante
esserci morto anche io alle spalle poco
ninja varese adro mazza questo qua è un
casino
devo centrare il buco mentre
[Musica]
cioè se non me lo merito io tanto questo
vuole dire il rumore di quando vinci
uguale più o meno cioè non so se ci
riprovo mille volte non ci riesco prova
bene
ma oggi sono così ragazzi on line race
che ho giocato per uno super nonno
specie al pro e arisa the wall
va bene la vincerò io mi impegno perché
si impegni con la bici ma è molto più
veloce non si sa come mai ma è così
perfetto molto bene mazza o siete
veramente competitivi ragazzi
non sono neanche mai arrivati eccolo se
mazuch e di nota una macchina fichissimo
se ci avesse anche il rumore del motore
sarebbe ancora meglio però l'arbre
magique che dondola fa tutto sono cagato
addosso sul serio ho visto natura
soccorre ok come un beh perchè le ha
cioè finale alla quentin tarantino
ragazzi complimenti thanks for flying va
bene grazie
complimenti stato con tre triple in che
senso
puoi andare uk a fare il tuo dovere
bravissimo l'uomo freccia
no perché l'acqua non è così facile devo
lanciare io chiuda subito praticamente
mamma mia cosa ho schivato a posto
ragazzi look sempre stato un problema
con questo gioco io ve lo dico ogni
volta che c'è lui dietro prende perdo
velocità e il gioco diventa un casino
quindi molto meglio non averlo
affidatevi a posto perfetto molto bene
ed è tutto ok
mazza ma è purtroppo hard perfetto
boltro ragazzi ogni almeno una volta
alla settimana un purtroppo devo fare e
cosa che mi rilassa di più prima che la
cosa per sbloccare la vittoria
esattamente sopra il forcone come faccio
dovrà avviare livello non vincerò mai ma
l'edizione wolf hall è cambiato e
cambiato livello sono riuscito a vincere
senza la vittoria prova sma a vincere
normalmente senza il coraggio forse era
meglio il golfo allora venivano chiuse
tedesco per karina loco victory ma
neanche per sbaglio hanno voglia col gol
non lo voglio maledizione vinci a
qualche hacker difficile no no no no ti
prego maledizione alla vita o se
riuscissi a trascinarmi di sopra a
maledizione è difficilissimo perché ti
manda di sotto in tempo zero
ok no dove non mandata dai ti prego
difficile adesso sono andate tutte nella
lock in
c'è mio dio ok
sì avevo preso il golfo ma vinco due
volte oggi perché sono una persona
capace ma questa roba chiamata happy
meal sfideranno fortuny sfidrà una
patologia arkia vasca tutto a posto
oh yeah
mamma mia che stava botto melo
dimenticato che c'è la sua più in ste
robe porca vacca che ricordi l'altro
molto questo lo vinco subito un tiro
solo se perdo cambio ho io io l'ho detto
e io io le sole cose le so jetpack run
bellissimo e un po violento pro carino
ma muoio muoio a caso fra l'altro ma
muoio a caso non ho capito perchè prima
sono morto hanno capito il motivo però
ok le scuole scuole sono uscite la gente
come perché si taglia testa a caso senza
un motivo però vabbè mi sono sempre
precisi chet baker han sempre se il mio
corpo non collabora ok ok basta che
rimanga attaccato io ho perso perché mi
sono schiantato contro il finale come fa
la mia vita essere così triste pagan
o perfetto importante essere intatti
vorrei fare ragazzi uno dei livelli
sempre master come finale tipo pyramid
of the gods c'è il 2 15 balconi of
terror bellissimo se sarà un must
ragazzi ora vi spiego balconi of terror
è un bel la balconata del terrore tu
devi arrivare alla fine intanto mentre
ti lanci giu ed è molto difficile perché
stanno i balconi tipo a napoli coi
vestiti attaccati però fisica di a una
velocità estrema tutto a posto
riproviamoci dovrebbe arrivare intatto
il più intanto possibile è
difficilissimo
cioè non c'è bisogno che lo spiega lo
vedete anche voi quanto è difficile c'è
proprio arrivare sotto infatti
un'impresa titanica però ok no mi stai
chiedendo che cosa posso tutto bene
tutto bene tutto ok ha opposto perfetto
sono arrivato vivo tanto questo sta
leggendo il giornale cosa che leggi ho
perso un braccio e basta no due braccia
vabbè dai però vi sia piaciuto ha
lasciato un bel like per il video se vi
è piaciuto iscrivetevi al canale e
schiacciate la campanella così da
rimanere aggiornati subito che escono e
iscrivetevi anche al secondo canale
perché faccio dire anche noi come sempre
ci vediamo ad un proseguito bella
ragazzi cosa ha giocato
[Musica]